mr thank you very much for being with us
uh unless i'm mistaken one of your books
was on osama bin laden's bookshelf how
do you feel about that
well it it certainly won me a lot of
friends when it was announced uh you
know four or five years ago
uh i i think it's simply there because i
listened to what osama bin laden said
he and al qaeda did what they said and i
i think that uh
we continue to
ignore what the enemy says and we we're
in the fix we are now uh because of that
sir
what will he have learned from your book
if he got around to reading it
he just would have he would have saw
what he said and and i what i tried to
do in the book is to just tell americans
or europeans whoever wanted to read it
was
here's a guy who's declared war on the
united states in a lot of people said
big deal
uh and i what i did was a correlation
between what he said and what they did
and they were doing everything he said
you know 75 or 80 percent of the time uh
he was he was uh
telegraphing to us what they intended to
do and why they did it
had nothing to do with our liberties and
freedom and women's rights and whiskey
and the rest of that nonsense it had to
do with intervention in their world
primarily support for the israelis
support for arab police states
and if anything under under mr cameron
and under mr obama we have enhanced
the motivation for the enemy to attack
us
certain amount of skepticism being
expressed about the timing and the
edited content of what's been released
now
do you share in that is this a sort of
counter counter-attack to
the pbs
questioning of the way in which obama
was tracked down
i i think sir it's less than uh the
questioning about the the capture or
killing or other of osama bin laden
then it has to do with the absolute
disaster uh that's going on in iraq at
the moment
you know one of the things osama bin
laden said is that the mujahideen the
islamists had to be careful not to get
off to too quick a start going after the
shia
because the shia
a war against the shia would be much
more popular than a war against the
americans
and if we if we were if we were paying
attention to what our nemesis uh had
said we would not be trying to get in
the middle of these people as they wage
a war
of sectarian nature
there are some who are saying that you
know al qaeda the notion of this
international terrorist network is
something that was sort of got up uh by
those people in the united states and
elsewhere who wanted to have a war on
terror and that they weren't really an
organized conspiracy what would you say
to that
i think they were very much organized uh
system sir they survived a lot of people
said they survived in afghanistan
because they were unstructured and
decentralized they were a very
structured organization and that's why
they survived the initial attack and
have
grown in in terms of geography and
manpower since
i think the letters themselves show the
nature of the organization the amount of
communication between
franchises or foreign offices if you
will and the commander and and i think
we need to remember too that for the
better part of a decade mr bush and then
mr obama and your prime ministers told
their people that
bin laden was isolated and couldn't
communicate with anyone and his threat
was diminishing for that reason these
documents and the documents that were
released in may 2012
show just the contrary